يقف الشعب الافغاني امام مفترق طرق وضعه
امامه قرار طالبان بمنع النساء من العمل
في منظمات غير حكوميه
والطالبات الافغانيات من التعليم الجامعي
فان لم تعد الحركه عن قرارها وهذا ما هو
متوقع على المدى القريب قد تواجه البلاد
شبح المجاعه وفق تحذيرات منظمات الاغاثه
في بلد يعتمد بشكل كبير على المساعدات
تداعيه شل نصف المجتمع الافغاني من
المتوقع ايضا ان تشكل خطرا يتعدى حدود
افغانستان
وفقما اكد مفوض الامم المتحده السامي
لحقوق الانسان
حتى الساعه ست منظمات اغاثيه علقت انشطتها
على الاراضي الافغانيه ما دفع حكما الى
توقف توزيع الاغذيه والمعدات الطبيه
والعلاجيه التي يحتاجها قسم كبير من
الافغان
وبالارقام يعتمدوا نحو 38 مليون افغاني من
اصل 41 على المساعدات الدوليه
وفي مؤشرين على تداعيات التعطيل تشغل على
سبيل المثال لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه ثمانيه
الاف افغاني بينهم ثلاثه الاف من النساء
اللجنه اصابها قرار طالبان فحذرت في بيان
لها من عجزها عن دي من الخدمات للمعوزيين
تاتي هذه التطورات غداه تحذير سابقا
لبرنامج الاغذيه العالميه الذي طلب بشكل
عاجل بمليار و 100 مليون دولار لمواصله
تقديم المساعدات الغذائيه خلال الاشهر
السته المقبله الى 18 مليون افغاني يعانون
من انعدام الامن الغذائي الحاد وسته
ملايين منهم على شفا المجاعه العربيه